انتهاء هدنه الاربع وعشرين ساعه في
السودان وسط حاله من الهدوء لم تجدها
الخرطوم من قبل منذ بدء صراع
على غريمه بايدن ويتهمه بسعر بسجنه
لابعاده عن المنافسه للترشح لرئاسه
الولايات المتحده
وفي روسيا خروج قطار عن القضبان وسقوط
مسيره وفي التزامن
يقر ببدء الهجوم المضاده
[موسيقى]
اهم الانباء من العربي
انتهت في هذه الاثناء الهدنه التي امتدت
لاربع وعشرين ساعه بين الطرفي الصراع في
السودان الهدنه التي دخلت حيز التنفيذ
صباح يوم امس
منحت سكان العاصمه متنفسا نادرا منذ بدء
المعارك قبل نحو شهرين
ومنذ بدء النزاع في ابريل الماضي ابرم
الجانبان اكثر من اتفاق لوقف النار سرعان
ما كان يتم خرقه من الطرفين
[موسيقى]
بنقول انه الهدنه حاجه كويسه خالص
ونتمنى ان تكون اكثر من كذا لان الاربعه
وعشرين ساعه حاجه ضيقه لكن اقول شيء من لا
شيء يعني نحن من هنا الطرفين انه يلتزموا
الجزام صارم بهدنه 24 ساعه
ومتفاعلين خير هي كويسه هسه لحد هسه ماشيه
كويسه
للحرب لانه الشعب السوداني عانما فيه
الكفايه 24 ساعه دي حقيقه ما بتعمل حاجه
يعني المفروض تكون اسبوع عشره يوم ان احنا
خلاص تعب
ولا عندنا مبلغ حاجه
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني مالك عقار
رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيه باحمد وطالب عقار
بضروره تفعيل اليه الايجاد لحل مشاكل
السودان من جانبه ابدى باحمد استعداده
لزياره الخرطوم للجلوس مع طرفي الصراع في
محاوله لوقف الحرب
[موسيقى]
قال الرسول صلى الله سابق في خطاب امام
صارح بعد توجيه لائحه اتهام اليه ان
الرئيس بايدن يحاول سجنه واصفا هذا التصرف
بما يفعله رؤساء دول العالم
انتم تشاهدون كيف يحاولوا سجن منافسه
السياسي الرئيسي فكر قليلا بذلك هذا تماما
ما يفعله قاده دول العالم الثالث الذين
يفضلون سجن خصومهم بدلا من مواجهتهم
انتخابيا الامر واضح وبسيط
امام انصاره ترامب يرد على الاتهامات
الموجهه اليه
وفي حديثه في مؤتمر للجمهوريين في ولايه
جورجيا ندد الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بما اعتبره اضطهادا ذو دوافع سياسيه
منتقدا الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ووزاره
العدل وما اسماه لائحه الاتهام المزيفه
لائحه تتضمن 37 تهمه وتضع الولايات
المتحده امام احتمال فوز مرشح يدير
الحكومه المقبله من وراء القضبان
كل ما يريدونه هو مقاضاه الجمهوريين من
خلالي رغم انني قمت بعمل عظيم خلال فتره
رئاسه هناك من انتقد الاتهامات واعتبرها
سخيفه لانه لا توجد جريمه لكنهم انفقوا
200 مليون دولار لمقاضاه بجريمه مزيفه
اكد انه ملاحق قضائيا لانه متقدم على بيض
بكثير في استطلاعات الراي الجديده واشار
الى انه لولا محاولته الفوز بولايه رئاسيه
ثانيه لما كانت هناك مطارده ولا اتهامات
سنضع حدا لسلسله الاخبار الكاذبه التي
يروج لها الديمقراطيون وفي نوفمبر 2024
سنقف بوجه الحكومه الديمقراطيه الفاسده
وسنخرج رئيسها بايدن من البيت الابيض
وسنكمل العمل الذي بداناه بنجاح لن اتوقف
عن القتال من اجلكم وفي حال ادانته فان
الحد الاقصى لعقوبه السجن التي يواجهها
ترامب تصل الى عشرين عاما
فالمقابل تعاهد حاكم ولايه فلوريدال
جمهوري والمرشح لرياسه الامريكيه
بتغيير مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
وتطهير وزاره العدل بالكامل اذا فاز في
الرئاسه
الاول ساغير مدير مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي سيتم تنظيف وزاره العدل من اعلى
الى اسفل سنستخدم سلطتنا لمحاسبه الاشخاص
وطرد اولئك الذين يسيئون استخدام سلطتهم
لا يمكن لوسائل الاعلام ان ترهبكم لا يمكن
لليسار ان يرعبكم
التهابات الجنايه الجديده التي تم توجيهها
للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
اثارت العديد من الاسئله المتعلقه
بمستقبله السياسي خاصه اكمال مشواره
للتنافس مره اخرى من اجل العوده الى البيت
الابيض
ترامب يواجه تهمه جنائيه للمره الثانيه
لاحتفاضه بوثائق سريه في منزله في فلوريدا
في الوقت الذي يخطط العودته الى البيت
الابيض وقبل اقل من شهرين اصبح اول رئيس
سابق في تاريخ الولايات المتحده يواجه
اتهامات جنائيه بعدما صوتت هيئه محلفين
كبرى في منهات بتوجيه الاتهام اليه لدوره
في دفع اموال لاسكات ممثله الافلام
الاباحيه
عشرات التهم تطارد ترامب تبرز معها العديد
من الاسئله المتعلقه بمستقبله السياسي
اهمها اذا كان لا يزال بامكانه اكمال
مشواره لمقعد الرئاسه مجددا وهو امر جائز
من الناحيه القانونيه فلا مانع من ترشح
ترامب حتى لو تمت ادانته لانه ببساطه
يمتلك المؤهلات الثلاث لمنصب الرئيس
ترامب من مواليد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا يقل عمره عن 35 عاما اقام في
الولايات المتحده لمده 14 سنه متواصله على
الاقل
الاهم من تلك الشروط هو ان الدستور
الامريكي لا يمنع اي شخص مدان او لديه سجل
اجرامي من الترشح لرئاسه البلاد ما يعني
انه في حال تم اعتقال ترامب فسيستطيع
اكمال واداره حملاته وهو بداخل زنزانته
بحسب لكن المشكله تظهر اذا فاز فعلا
فانتخاب رئيس لا يلغي التهم المرفوعه ضده
كما ان المنصب لا يخرجه من السجن في حال
الحكم بادانه ترامب بعد فوزه بالانتخابات
فليس امامه الا ان يبقى في السجن او يدفع
غرامه للحصول على حكم بوقف التنفيذ وحينها
سيصبح اول رئيس امريكي يتعرض للادانه من
ناحيتها ترى مجله
واضحه حتى الان لما سيحدث حال ادانه ترامب
قبل او بعد فوزه بالانتخابات ولا يعرف احد
مصير القضايا المرفوعه ضده لكن المؤكد هو
ان الولايات المتحده قد تواجه ازمه
دستوريه على اعلى مستوى
[موسيقى]
سقطت طائره مسيره في اقليم محاذي للعاصمه
الروسيه موسكو في ساعه مبكره من صباح
اليوم وقال حاكم المنطقه انه لم تقع
عصابات بسبب الحادث ولم يتسنى لوكاله
رويترز التي اوردت الخبر التحقق بشكل
مستقل من ذلك
وفي مقاطع قبل جراده روسيه اعلن حاكمها عن
خروج 15 عربه شحن عن السكك الحديديه في
منطقه حدوديه مع اوكرانيا وقال حاكم
المقاطع انه ليس هناك اي اصابات بالارواح
لان القطار كان فارغا واشار ايضا الى ان
حركه القطارات في المنطقه لم تتعطل وانه
يجري العمل لتحديد اسباب الحادثه
الحرب تابى ان تضع اوزارها في اوكرانيا بل
الحديث الان عن هجوم اوكراني مضاد يكون قد
بدا منذ فتره
الرئيس بوتين يقول انه فشل منذ بدايته
والرئيس زيلينسكي يشير الى انها البدايه
فقط كل طرف يواصل حشد قواته والنار تستعر
اكثر فاكثر التطورات على الارض تفيد بان
صافره الانذار دوت في ثلاث مقاطعات
اوكرانيه في شرق ووسط البلاد الامر يتعلق
قبل ذلك سمع دوي صفارات الانذار في
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها اوكرانيا في
مقاطعه
ومناطق اخرى في الاثناء وبلغه يغلب عليها
الكثير من التحفظ قال الرئيس الاوكراني
فولو ديمير ان عمليه الهجوم المضاد جاريه
بالفعل لكنه لم يفصح عن تفصل اكثر
من المهم ان تشعر روسيا دائما بانه لم
يتبقى لها الكثير من الوقت في رايي تجري
عمليات هجوميه ودفاعيه مضاده في اوكرانيا
في هذه المرحله لن اتحدث بالتفصيل هيئه
الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه قالت ان قواتها
صدت هجمات معاديه حول باخموت ومارينكا حيث
تدور اشتباكات عنيفه في الشرق مشيره الى
ان القوات الروسيه ما زالت تتكبد خسائر
فادحه تحاول اخفائها من جانبها تقول موسكو
ان اوكرانيا شنت هجوما ضخما قبل ايام لكن
قوات كياف لم تتمكن من اختراق دفاعاتها هي
حرب مستمره انتقلت من فتره المواجهه الى
مرحله كسر العظام ففي الوقت الذي يستمر
فيه الغرب بتزويد اوكرانيا بالذخيره حصلت
روسيا على 130 الف طنين من الذخيره في
العام الاول من بيلاروسيا وفاتوره الدم
والرصاص
تستمر في الارتفاع
بلال البشتين العربيه
قال حاكم منطقه خرسون الموالي لروسيا
فلاديمير سالدو انه من المرجح ان يعود
منسوب المياه في الرافد الجنوبي لنهر الى
مستواه الطبيعي الى مستواه الطبيعي بحلول
السادس عشر من يونيو بعد فيضان هائل نتج
عن تدمير سد كخوفكار الاوكراني في الاسبوع
الماضي وقال منسوب المياه في بلده نوفا
كخوفكا المجاور للسد انخفض الان بمقدار
ثلاثه امتار من ذروه يوم الثلاثاء وان
عمليات ضخ المياه وجمع القمامه من الشوارع
قد بدات
ما زالت وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه تعمل بجهد
من اجل انقاذ العالقين فوق سطوح المنازل
والبيوت
لقد غرق كل شيء داخل البيت وشكرا جزيلا
للطوارئ على المساعده تقول السلطات
المحليه في هذه المقاطعه مقاطعه خرسون وفي
اداره مدينه نوفيكخوفكا بان منسوب المياه
بدا ينخفض من المناطق السكنيه
لقد سمعت صوتا انفجار السد وعدت للبيت
وبعدها بدات المياه تتدفق نعم عدت للبيت
وقال القائم باعمال الرئاسه في خرسون بان
المتضررين في المقاطعه بمجملها بلغت
اعدادهم اربعين الفا
لقد كنت في مقاطعه ريستوف وعجلت في العوده
الى هنا ساذهب لارى احوال منزلي انا لا
اعرف شيئا وقال سالدو بان عمليات التنظيف
في هذه المنطقه ستستمر لثلاثه ايام على
الاقل
تثبت كيف تعتقد كان شعورنا نعم هي الصدمه
والهستيريا طبعا كيف يمكن التصور ذلك انظر
الى الارض حتى اليوم لم تجف المياه فكل
شيء غارق
وقال عمده مدينه نوفيكا خوفكا بان المحطه
الكهرومائيه قد غرقت باكملها في المياه
وانه لا يمكن تشغيلها الا بعد انتهاء
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
العسكريون هنا قالوا بان الالغام التي
كانت قد زرعت ما بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والقوات الروسيه قد جرفتها المياه الى
مناطق مختلفه في مدينه نوفاك خوفكا
وضواحيها
الالغام نعم هي الالغام وكان من المفترض
ان نموت لولا الجدار الذي منع المصيبه كان
ممكنا ان نصبح جثثا جزء كبير من المواطنين
رفضوا ترك بيوتهم وفضلوا البقاء على
الذهاب الى الملاجئ وتشير المصادر
العسكريه ان هذا الانجراف وهذه الفيضانات
تسببت بعرقله تنقلات جنود الروس على
الجبهه لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
نوفا
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
رسولنا امريكيه يتهم الصين باداره منشاه
تجسس في كوبا منذ سنوات
وادخلت عليها تعديلات عمل 2000 وتسعه عشر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رسولنا ملكي نصين
تدير منشره تجسس في كوبا منذ سنوات وادخلت
عليها تطويرات عام 2019
واكد ان حضور الاستخبارات الصينيه في
الجزيره وذلك بعد ان ذكرت وسائل اعلام
الامريكيه في الايام الاخيره ان بكين
تعتزم اقامه قاعده التجسس قاعده تجسس في
كوبا قباله سواحل الجنوب شرق الولايات
المتحده
مصدر قلق امريكي جديد من الصين الملف هو
التجسس والمكان هو كوبا الاداره الامريكيه
تحاول التعامل مع هذا الخطر وفق بوليتيكو
رغم نفي البيت الابيض والبنتاجون قيام
الصين بانشاء القاعده ووسط اللغط الذي
احيط بهذه القضيه اكد مسؤول امريكي ان
الصين انشات بالفعل قاعده تجسس في كوبا
وان اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اطلعت
على عدد من القواعد الحساسه في جميع انحاء
العالم ومن ضمنها القاعده الموجوده في
كوبا منذ يناير العام 2021
المصدر نفسه اكد ان بكين انشات هذه
القاعده منذ العام 2019 وليس كما افادت
المعلومات بانها اتفقت مع هافانا على
انشائها مستقبلا بايدن وبحسب المسؤول
الامريكي وجه ادارته بمعالجه تلك القضيه
خلال اشهر دون الافصاح عن مزيد من
التفاصيل مسؤولون امريكيون مطلعون على
معلومات استخباراتيه سريه للغايه لفتوا في
وقت سابق الى ان تلك المنصه التي ستقام في
الجزيره على بعد حوالي 100 ميلا من
فلوريدا الامريكيه ستتيح لاجهزه المخابرات
الصينيه الحصول على الاتصالات الالكترونيه
في جميع انحاء جنوب شرقي الولايات المتحده
حيث توجد العديد من القواعد العسكريه وفق
ما نقلت صحيفه
وجود مثل تلك القاعده ذات القدرات
العسكريه والاستخباراتيه المتقدمه في
الفناء الخلفي لامريكا يشكل بلا شك تهديدا
صينيا جديدا غير مسبوق بالنسبه لواشنطن
لاسيما وسط ارتفاع مستوى التوتر بين
البلدين منذ فتره اياد حمود العربيه
[موسيقى]
قبل زياره مرتقبه الى تونس لقاده اوروبيين
قالقين بشارع عدد المهاجرين الذين يعبرون
ويعبرون البحر المتوسط قال الرئيس تونسي
قيس سعيد ان تونس لن تقبل ان تصبح حارس
حدود لدول اخرى واضاف سعيد نازله لمدينه
صفاقس الساحليه نقطه الانطلاق الرئيسيه
للمهاجرين ان الحل لن يكون على حساب بلده
مشيرا الى انه لا يمكن لتونس ان تقوم
بالدور الذي يفصح عنه البعض ويخفيه البعض
الاخر وفق تعبيره تاتي ذلك بعد ان قالت
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني
انها ورئيس الوزراء الهولندي مارك روتين
ورئيسه مفوضيه الاتحاد الاوروبي اورسولا
بوندا لاين سيعرضون المساعده خلال زياره
لتونس التي تواجه ازمه في الماليه العامه
نحن نحن المسؤوليه الكبيره في الحفاظ على
الدوله وعلى سيادتها
ولا نقبل بان يعامل اي شخص معامله غير
انسانيه
هو نعمل على ان يكون كل من يفيد الى تونس
في وضعيه قانونيه هؤلاء ضحايا ضحايا نظاما
عالمي للاسف يتعامل معهم لا كذاوات بشريه
ولكن مجرد ارقام
ولا يمكن ايضا ان نقوم بالدور الذي
يفسح عنه البعض
ويخفيه البعض الاخر بان نكون حراسا
لدولهم لا الحل لا يمكن ان يكون الا
انسانيا وجمعيا بناء على مقاييس انسانيه
ولكن في ظل القانون
بدات بمدينه اكادير المغربيه فعاليه
الدوره التاسعه عشره من مناورات الاسد
الافريقيه الذي تنظمه المغرب والولايات
المتحده تستمر هذه المناورات حتى السادس
عشر من شهر يونيو الجاري ويتضمن برنامج
هذه الدوره تمارين في التخطيط العملياتي
الى جانب عدد من التدريبات التكتيكيه التي
ستجرى ضرا وجوارا
بمشاركه 240 من المظليين من الامريكان ومن
المغاربه تتابع في عمليات الانزال المشترك
من الطائرات العسكريه بعد انزال لعتاد
حربي في محاكاه لارض المواجهه العسكريه
الاسد الافريقي يعكس علاقه صداقه قديمه مع
المغرب في الحفاظ على الامن ففي كل يوم
نقوم بتجارب ميدانيه تؤكد عمق هذه الصداقه
ما قمنا بتنفيذه ميدنيا عمليه جويه مشتركه
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والمغرب
في مجال الطيران العسكري في اكبر تدريب
ميداني لافريكوم حضور للطب العسكري لاجلاء
المصابين والقيام بالتدخلات الطبيه
الاستعجاليه في ساحات المعارك تم القيام
بتمرين الانزال الجوي بمدينه بن جرير
وفي هذا الاطار تم انشاء واحد طبيه اللي
مكلفه بالاسعافات الاوليه وبالاستشارات
الطبيه هاد الانشاء ديال هذه الوحده
تعاون مع الفرق الطبيه الامريكيه وهذا
الشيء يمكننا باننا نحسنوا من المكتسبات
ديالنا ومن الخبرات ديالنا في اطار طب
العملياتي بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والمغرب عمل عسكري ثنائي لدعم الامن
والاستقرار في افريقيا
بمشاركه اكثر من سته الاف من الجنود في
تداريب الاسد الافريقي بعد ايام طويله من
التحضير في قواعد عسكريه جويه مغربيه
تمرين ميداني بين القوات المسلحه الملكيه
المغربيه والجيش الامريكي لانزال المظليين
مع عمليه انزال لسياره عسكريه ومدفعيه
ثقيله تمرير يتطلب تنسيقا وتدقيقا في
مراحل التنفيذ عادل الزبير للعربيه وللح
دث منطقه بن جرير في ضواحي مدينه مراكش
وسط المغرب
[موسيقى]
في اسرائيل تجددت الاحتجاجات للاسبوع
الثالث والعشرين احتجاجا على مشروع قانون
الاصلاح القضائي الذي تدعمه حكومه بنيامين
نتنياه
وجهت تهمه محاوله القتل الى اللاجئ سوريا
الذي طعن سته اشخاص بينهم اربعه اطفال في
حديقه بمدينه انسيا الفرنسيه وقالت
المدعيه العامه في المدينه ان الرجل
البالغ من العمر 31 عاما لا يزال ملتزما
الصمت حتى الان بشان دافعه بينما يوجد في
حجز الشرطه وقبل وقبل عرضه عرضه على قاضي
التحقيق
واكدت ان خبراء طب النفسي اعتبرت حاله
المعتدي قابله لاحتجازه لدى الشرطه
فتره احتجازه الاولى انتهت ووضع قيد الحبس
الاحتياطي منفذ هجوم انسي الذي اعتدى
بالسكين على اطفال دون سن الثالثه يواجه
تهمتين هما الشروع في القتل واستخدام سلاح
لمقاومه الشرطه وبحسب المدعيه العامه فان
عبد المسيح خضع لفحوصا تثبت ان وضعه
النفسي يسمح بمواصله توقيفه
خلال احتجازه يعرض مره على طبيبين اعلن ان
وضعه النفسي يسمح بمواصله توقيفه لم يظهر
اي دافع ارهابي في هذه المرحله ولا يزال
مكتب المدعي العام في انسي كالعاده على
اتصال بمكتب المدعي العام لمكافحه الارهاب
دوافع معتدي ما زالت مشهوله مع استبعاد
فرضيات الارهاب كما اشارت المدعيه العامه
لكن بمعزل عن الدوافع فان الهجوم الذي وقع
في وضح النهار وفي حديقه اطفال عامه سبب
صدمه كبيره لدى سكان المدينه الهادئه هذا
اخافني لدينا خوف من هؤلاء الاشخاص غير
الطبيعيين لا اشعر بالخوف ابدا بل
بالكراهيه لكن لن نغير حياتنا اليوميه
بسبب اشخاص قادرين على فعل اشياء مروعه
كهذه ووفقا للتحقيق فقد عثر بحوزه المعتدي
بعد احتجازه على السكين التي استخدمها في
الاعتداء وعلى شعارين مسيحيين وصليبا
ورخصه قياده سويديه لم تنجح التحقيقات
الاوليه في تحديد دوافع منفذ اعتداء انسي
وبقي سر هذا اللاجئ لغزا تحاول الشرطه
والقضاء هل له وسط اجواء مشحونه يغذيها
يميلون متطرفون يجدون في الهجوم فرصه
لترويج سياستهم المتشدده في ملف الهجره
واللجوء زينه عادي العربيه باريس
رفضت شركه تويتر دفع فواتير خدمه جوجل
للحوسبه لان عقدها على وشك التجديد هذا
الشهر وقال تقرير لموقع بلاك بورمر
الاخباري انه قبل استحواذ ايلون ماسك على
منصه التواصل الاجتماعي العام الماضي وقبل
ذلك وقع تويتر عقدا لعده اعوام من جوجل
يتعلق بمكافحه البريد العشوائي وحمايه
الحسابات من بين امور اخرى ولم يقدم
التقارير التقرير تفاصيل حول كيف امكانيه
ان يؤدي الصراع بين الشركتين الى عرقله
عمل فرقه الثقه والامان في تركيا
الى العالم
انتهاء هدنه الاربع وعشرين ساعه في
السودان وسط حاله من الهدوء لم تشهدها
الخرطوم من قبل منذ بدء
هجوما ضاريا على غريمه
بالسعي لسجنه لابعاده عن المنافسه للترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسي
وفي روسيا خروج قطار عن القضبان وسقوط
مسيره وبتزامن
الهجوم المضاد
نهايه النشره الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات